>> Sean: LAST NIGHT, MICHAEL
AVENATTI WAS ARRESTED ON
SUSPICION OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
CHARGES.
IT DIDN'T TAKE LONG FOR
HOLLYWOOD LIBERALS LIKE ALYSSA
MILANO TO DISAVOW HIM, AND
SUDDENLY, THEY ARE FANS OF DUE
PROCESS.
>> IT WAS VERY UPSETTING TO
HEAR, IT WAS VERY DISAPPOINTING.
IF IT PROVES TO BE TRUE, I WILL
DISAVOW HIM.
I THINK HE SHOULD TAKE A
POLYGRAPH TEST JUST TO CLEAR THE
AIR AND I THINK THAT WOULD HELP
HIM.
AND WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> WHAT DRIVES ME CRAZY IS THE
HYPOCRISY, AND IF YOU BELIEVE IN
DUE PROCESS WITH KAVANAUGH THEN
YOU SHOULD ALSO BELIEVE IN DUE
PROCESS WITH MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> WE DON'T KNOW A LOT OR WHO
THE ALLEGED VICTIM IS BUT IF
TRUE, I'M SO DISAPPOINTED.
I'M SO DISAPPOINTED AND I AGREE
WITH YOU, WE WOULD HAVE TO
DISAVOW HIM.
>> Sean: MEDIA IS SUCH A
DIFFERENT TONE ESPECIALLY
COMPARED TO THE WAY THEY TREATED
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
JOINING US NOW IS MONICA CROWLE
CROWLEY,          ARI
FLEISCHER.
REPUBLICANS SCREW THINGS UP A
LOT, THEY REALLY DO.
ONE OF THE THINGS I GAVE HIM
CREDIT FOR, THEY HANDLED THE
CAVANAUGH           AND
KAVANAUGH CASE WITH THE
SERIOUSNESS IT DESERVED.
THEY WENT THROUGH THE HEARINGS
AND WENT THROUGH THE EVIDENCE,
AND NOW, WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE HE'S BEING INVESTIGATED.
I BELIEVE IN DUE PROCESS,
MICHAEL AVENATTI DID NOT.
NOW YOU SEE THE MEDIA TONE
CHANGED.
>> NUMBER ONE, I TAKE NO JOY IN
THIS.
BUT DUE PROCESS, AND YOU ARE
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY,
CAN NEVER BE SLOGANS IN AMERICA,
THEY MUST BE REAL.
THEY MUST BE HOW OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS BUILT.
MICHAEL AVENATTI HAD NO RESPECT
FOR EITHER, INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY, OR DUE PROCESS.
NOW IT'S COME FULL CIRCLE AND HE
HAS TO DEAL WITH IT.
HE'S LUCKY BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE
BRETT KAVANAUGH WHO BELIEVE IN
THE CONSTITUTION, AND IF THAT
TURNS OUT TO BE TRUE, APPARENTLY
WHEN HE RAN IN, THIS IS THE DAY
AFTER, AND THE WORDS, SHE HIT ME
FIRST.
IF THAT CAME OUT AND THAT'S
TRUE, THAT'S PROBLEMATIC IN MY
MIND.
THAT WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC FOR
ANYBODY.
>> IS THAT HIS DEFENSE?
SHE HIT ME FIRST?
ALL OF THESE HOLLYWOOD LIBERALS
AND OTHERS WHO EMBRACE MICHAEL
AVENATTI AS SOME SORT OF HERO OF
THE RESISTANCE, THEY ARE ALL
LEARNING RIGHT NOW THAT YOU LIVE
BY THE MICHAEL AVENATTI AND YOU
DIE BY THAT.
HE WILL HAVE HIS DAY IN COURT,
AND HE WAS FIRST IN LINE TRYING
TO DENY THAT.
AND BROUGHT BY THE WAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WELL WITH HIS
REPRESENTATION OF STORMY DANIEL
DANIELS.
HE'S GOING TO A VERY MESSY
DIVORCE AND HIS EX-WIFE IS A
SWORN STATEMENT IN THOSE
PROCEEDINGS WHERE SHE CLAIMED
THAT HE EMOTIONALLY ABUSED HER.
SO THERE MAY OR MAY NOT BE A
PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR HERE WITH
MR. MICHAEL AVENATTI.
BUT THE FACT THAT THE LEFT JUST
BLINDLY RACED TO EMBRACE HIM
ONLY BECAUSE HE OPPOSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WAS TRYING
TO LEAD THE CHARGE TO TAKE ON
CASES TO TRY TO DESTROY HIM IS
DESPICABLE.
>> Sean: ON MSNBC, OVER 100.
BUT WHAT ABOUT, WHEN THESE
ISSUES COME UP, PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW ANY OF THE FACTS, THEY
DON'T KNOW IF ALLEGATIONS HAVE
BEEN MADE TO, NO CORROBORATION.
THEN YOU GET DEEPER INTO IT,
LIKE IN THE CASE OF PROFESSOR
FORD.
THEY IDENTIFIED AN EYEWITNESS
WHO SAID IT DIDN'T HAPPEN IN
THAT CASE.
JULIE SWETNICK'S STORY WAS SO
OVER-THE-TOP AND THEN SHE
CHANGED HER STORY.
BUT WHEN PEOPLE SAY, I BELIEVE
HER, WITHOUT KNOWING ANYTHING
ABOUT THE CASE, -- BECAUSE THAT
HAPPENS A LOT.
WHEN SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS ARE
MADE WE NEED TO TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY.
>> AND THE WOMEN WHO MADE THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST BILL CLINTON
ARE STILL LARGELY NOT BELIEVED
BY THOSE ON THE LEFT.
IT'S A TERRIBLE HYPOCRISY.
IF IT'S A WOMAN WHO IS TALKING
OR SAYING THAT REPUBLICAN DID
SOMETHING WRONG OR IMMORAL, THE
ENTIRE LEFT SAYS WOMEN SHOULD BE
BELIEVED, RIGHT FROM THE START
WITH NO INVESTIGATION NECESSARY.
I BELIEVE.
YET NOW THEY ARE ALL PAUSING.
IT SHOULD BE A CONSTANT
STANDARD, THE REPUBLICAN
STANDARD.
IT SHOULD BE A DUE PROCESS
STANDARD, THE INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY STANDARD.
THE LEFT NEEDS TO STOP THIS, I
BELIEVE ANYBODY, WHEN THEY
ATTACKED THE REPUBLICANS.
>> THESE ISSUES ARE TOO SERIOUS,
THESE CHARGES ARE TOO SERIOUS
AND THE ISSUE IS TOO SERIOUS.
NOBODY WANTS ANYBODY THAT ABUSES
WOMEN TO GET AWAY WITH IT,
NOBODY WITH A CONSCIENCE OR A
SOUL.
WHAT ABOUT THE, I BELIEVE,
BEFORE WE KNOW ANYTHING?
>> WE ARE STARTING TO SEE A
TURNING OF THIS.
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT STARTED OUT
AS A VERY NOBLE PURPOSE.